comment se déroule la mobilisation à
écouter samantha une petite centaine de
salariés de l'entreprise sanofi de vitry
et bien à vient d'arriver il ya une
quinzaine de minutes pour soutenir leurs
collègues et une prise de parole a lieu
en ce moment même et un procès
symbolique de sanofi va avoir lieu d'ici
quelques quelques minutes alors ses
salariés de sanofi protestent contre la
suppression de 3 164 emplois dans les
secteurs de la recherche et du
développement
dans le même temps eh bien on apprend
que sanofi et bien elle a réalisé 11
milliards de chiffre d'affaires l'an
dernier distribué plus de 4 milliards
d'euros de dividendes à ses actionnaires
une situation que ne comprennent pas à
ses salariés derrière moi et donc vous
l'avez dit plusieurs élus politiques le
sont de passage sur cette manifestation
pour et bien soutenir ses salariés parmi
ces personnalités politiques figurent à
clémentine autain député de la france
soumise de seine saint denis
bonjour merci de nous accorder cette
interview alors pourquoi vous êtes vous
être déplacé pour ce rassemblement choix
c'est un projet de l'entreprise sanofi
et je crois que c'est légitime pour
accompagner la mobilisation des salariés
et vous avez remarqué d'ailleurs qui à
la poêle et sanofi et des salariés de
grandpuits en colère contre total parce
que font ces des mines logique assez
similaire si vous avez des grands
groupes qui décide de faire davantage de
profits au mépris du sort des salariés
et au mépris du bien commun pour sanofi
c'est assez clair puisqu'on sait très
bien que les décennies
ça remet en jeu loin malheureusement ou
progressivement sanofi 1 limiter le
nombre d'emplois pour la recherche face
à des conséquences puisque nous sommes à
la traîne aujourd'hui et les derniers de
la classe privé en accents de programme
nous dénoncions utilisé finalement la
logique du grip qui préfèrent rémunérer
ses actionnaires que
de mettre le paquet investir dans ce qui
est fondamental pour nos vies pour le
bien commun
évidemment c'est facile aussi
d'incriminer l'entreprise derrière ce
sont des choix politiques qui permettent
au siège entreprises de faire justement
vous pensez que c'est une mauvaise
stratégie qui à terme va nuire à
l'entreprise
ça ne vit pas simplement à l'entreprise
la nuit à ce qui est très important pour
nous citoyens des citoyens qui avons
besoin de produire en france
les médicaments ou c'est que par exemple
le doliprane pourrait ne plus être
produit en france si on continue comme
ça et ça c'est dramatique
si on n'a pas de souveraineté de ce
qu'en brûlant du point de vue de la
production de médicaments aux captives
nous c'est que les conséquences peuvent
être absolument dramatique
et deuxièmement si on n'investit pas
dans la recherche qui n'est pas toujours
rentable à court terme est bien là ça
devient une cata une catastrophe et on
l'a vu avec le vaccin opus qu'on défend
c'est un pôle public du médicament pour
que nous puissions nous même gérer en
fait ce secteur est un secteur clé pour
la santé vous pensez que le gouvernement
doit avoir son mot à dire sur ce genre
de dossier
bien sûr et c'est même incroyable qui
n'est pas sonné c'est à dire qu'en fait
les pouvoirs publics très longtemps se
sont dégagés de ses responsabilités de
cette intervention nécessaire qui
signifie démocratie démocratie là où la
loi du profit a pris finalement toute la
place au détriment le du bien commun
merci ans clémentine autain la voix
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes député
la france est soumise de seine saint
denis dont clémentine vu autant qui est
bien est favorable à la mise en place
d'un pôle public des médicaments et qui
déplore cette situation
de sanofi qui continue et bien
d'apporter son soutien est derrière moi
vous voyez peut-être le procès sans
bolivien de sanofi qui a d'ores et déjà
commencé avec plusieurs chefs
d'accusation visiblement qui ont déjà
été annoncés merci beaucoup nadège
abderrazak ou suivez donc cette
mobilisation des salariés de sanofi à à
partir et non pas à gentilly merci à
vous faut